es un despido que llega más tarde de lo
que se esperaba según los críticos y que
sin duda tendrá un impacto en los planes
de Richie sunak por marcar una distancia
con los escándalos que tanto
persiguieron árboles Johnson nadisa
guabo y fue despedido esta mañana por
romper el código ministerial por a
mentir sobre sus asuntos Fiscales dado
que era uno de los hombres claves del
gobierno al ser el jefe del partido
conservador una posición altísima y muy
privilegiada Sahuayo y cuando fue
ministro de salud de finanzas mintió que
había sido investigado por la oficina
Nacional de impuestos y que llegó a un
acuerdo con esta por 5 millones de
libras por evasión de impuestos esta
mañana en una carta el Primer Ministro
Richie sunak ha dicho que después de la
finalización de la investigación de un
asesor independiente está claro que ha
habido una violación grave del código
ministerial desde que fue elegido de
octubre Richi es una que ha tenido que
despedir dos ministros por polémicas
esto sin duda Tiene un gran impacto en
el futuro del partido conservador de
Cara a las elecciones generales de 2024
Dado que los laboristas cada vez más les
pisan los talones